please welcome emily radakowski
[Applause]
i've been watching every interview too
oh god by the way how was howard stern
yeah i just came from howard it's weird
i like did an hour and a half it's the
longest interview i think i've done with
someone and he was great well i
he you know he used to be a big button
pusher in my life because he would have
my mom on all the time
and i've done his shows a bunch of times
now yeah he's the man i truly respect
which just goes to show he also talks
about therapy and change
and we grow up and we have different
opinions and feelings about things so i
want to get into all of that with you
please that's why i'm here okay good
well let's start with mom because that
really affected me in your book
and i'm just curious your mom feeds you
a lot of messages of
your looks your beauty
how
do you think that formed you
yeah i mean i think that every woman i
was really interested in talking about
mother-daughter relationships because
every woman i know their mom sort of
instilled this messaging of this is how
you're gonna survive in the world um you
know whether it was with negative
comments or kind of like paying too much
attention to the way they look or saying
you know it's important to be thin or
you know just any kind of subliminal
messaging that comes through in really
small ways and i think that
moms i'm a mom now um you kind of you
don't realize that you're even doing
that and it's a response to your own
experiences my mom's father was very um
his attitude was like you should never
say thank you when um when somebody says
you're beautiful because you haven't
done anything to deserve it so she like
you haven't earned your beauty so it's
not a real compliment so she had a lot
of shame around the way she looked and
complicated you know conflicted feelings
so when it came to me she was very like
you know you own it you do your thing i
had puberty very young
and she was like just celebrate your
body do you know whatever
she also um you know saw modeling as a
great way to make money potentially for
for somebody who um you know she was a
english professor my dad was a high
school art teacher and all of my friends
were working service industry jobs and
she was like this could be a great way
for her to make money
and i think in some ways she didn't
realize that you know
what happened and i write about this in
the book that is i would lay in bed and
pray to be beautiful i didn't pray to be
super smart or for safety or all the
things that somebody could pray for um
i wanted to be beautiful and i think you
know it wasn't just her it was the whole
kind of world
saying that's how women become powerful
become successful i saw men who were
presidents and rock stars and actors and
they all seemed really powerful but to
me the most powerful women were the most
beautiful and like the sexiest so i i
wanted that
now when you talk about the blurred
lines video um which as i read that
chapter in the book i was interested
going into it because i had heard a lot
about it in the public
when you're writing that do you know
this is going to grab this is going to
pop and and rise to the top
what were your thoughts i didn't want to
write it i didn't want to write the
essay um you know but it was something
that i had talk about evolution in my
20s i had always said i felt so
empowered on that video which by the way
is still true i had an amazing time on
that setup all women chris women's
directors
compared to other jobs i was doing at
that point it was the most fun i'd ever
had and i think it reflects in the in
the video you know you can see that i'm
being silly and having fun yeah they're
encouraging that yes goofy it was sweet
yes it was fun yes and it felt like i
was dancing for my girlfriends like a
slumber party or something there was
permission yeah and you know for a long
time i sort of said to the world like
this is empowerment feminism is about
choice look at i've had this success i
felt great about my body like but that
wasn't the whole experience on the video
um there were power dynamics at play
even though it was a bunch of women um
it was you know very clear who was in
charge and there were ways that you know
as somebody who's working a job you know
i wasn't protected and it was it felt
like i was obligated you know for the
book itself because it's a huge theme is
how i've evolved and you know looking
taking a harder look at experiences that
i'd sort of said
that was that it was this simple and
saying no there's also this other side
you know it's nuanced and he he is in
charge it's his video i didn't know also
that he had been drinking yeah and
you're in a video
and you're thinking you know what do you
think is it him thinking i'm gonna
grab you and and this is going to be a
great moment you know for the video
possibly is it just lost in the sauce is
it not being told this is
this is a no-touch situation and i so
understand the walking away confused and
not realizing until later yeah
but when you realize later you like i'm
realizing that now this is going to
color the whole book or through it i'm
going to talk about it and my book's
going to rise above and around that one
headline yeah so that was hard you know
that's why i didn't want to write it as
i knew that that would be the only part
of the book that people would focus on
in some ways it would be the the juicy
headline and everyone was like
yes celebrity you know memoir um
but i i did think it was important
because i had said i'd spoken out so
much about that video before and i
wanted to set the record straight about
you know how i've evolved and and um my
beliefs have changed but yeah it's been
a little you know i hope people actually
get to read at one point i was going to
publish the essay online so it was
accessible
but they wanted to do sort of a
like a
trimmed down version and i was like no
no i want every single word that's in
the book to be read so i'm hoping that
when people read the actual essay
they're able to understand what i was
getting at
[Music]